مشاهدينا ان نتابع ايضا هذه الصور
المباشره لمظاهرات في العاصمه بغداد ضد
غلاء الاسعار وتراجعي قيمه الدينار على
مدى اكثر من شهرين هو سعر صرف الدينار
العراقي مشاهدينا يتراجع امام الدولار
الامريكي
بوتيره تصاعديه وبشكل شبه يومي حيث وصل
سعر الصرف الخميس والجمعه الماضيين الى
عتبه الى عتبه 170 الف دينار وبلغ ايضا في
بعض الاسواق والبورصات الماليه نحو
175 الف دينار لكل 100 دولار وهو رقم
قياسي لم يسبق تسيله من قبل احدى معكم في
متابعه هذه الصور المباشره لمظاهرات في
العاصمه العراقيه بغداد احتجاجا على
تراجعي قيمه الدينار امام الدولار هذه
الاحتجاجات مشاهدينا تاتي ايضا على بحيات
اخرى قبل اكثر من اسبوع كانت امام البنك
المركزي العراقي احتجاج على الانخفاض
المستمر
صرف الدينار امام الدولار
[موسيقى]